une rencontre annuelle se déroule ces
jours-ci à ottawa pour permettre à des
employeurs des syndicats des groupes
environnementaux d'échanger avec les
représentants du canada de l'union
européenne un cadre de la mise en oeuvre
de l'accord économique commerciale et
globale et samuel le responsable du
plaidoyer à la fondation nicolas hulot
qui fait partie des deux représentants
des ong européen à y participer
on va le retrouver dans nos studios à
ottawa bonsoir monsieur le riz bonsoir
alors quel est le message que vous
souhaitez porter au gouvernement
canadien entre autres aujourd'hui c'est
un message qui s'adresse à l'union
européenne comme comme au canada c'est
de dire on a un accord de commerce qui
fait pas du tout l'unanimité il ya
beaucoup d'oppositions partout en europe
vous savez quand en europe le processus
de ratification est pas terminée et que
pour nous il n'est pas compatible
aujourd'hui avec les engagements pris
dans le cadre de l'accord de paris que
ce soit de la part du canada où l'union
européenne parce que sur les 1500 96
pages que fond l'accord il ya que
seulement 13 pages sur l'environnement
et que c'est 13 pages ne sont pas
contraignantes
contrairement à tout le reste de
l'accord donc vous souhaiteriez qu'on
modifie l'accord vous parlait même de
renégociation carrément oui en fait ce
qu'on propose d'ailleurs c'était prévu
dans l'accord c'est est ce qu'on appelle
une review donc de revoir les chapitres
développement durable et plus
généralement nous on demande de revoir
la carte revoir d'accord pour faire quoi
d'abord pour mettre une clause
environnementale on voit un peu que
partout dans le monde
ça devient un peu de tendance d'être
contre le climat on le voit aux états
unis au brésil et donc on a besoin
d'avoir des garanties pour que dans
l'avenir tous les états tiennent leurs
objectifs climatiques donc nous ce qu'on
propose c'est une clause qui permettent
aux états si jamais le canada ou si
jamais l'union européenne ne respecte
pas ses engagements de baisse
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
alors de suspendre l'accord le temps que
l'on revienne sur la bonne trajectoire
donc de le suspendre carrément on sait
qu'il est en vigueur depuis un an
pourquoi pas simplement l'amendé
modifier certaines choses alors qu'il
pourrait rester en vigueur
alors c'est ça qu'on propose c'est de
l'amendé pour au cas où si jamais le
canada ou si jamais l'union européenne
ne tiennent pas leurs engagements ils
puissent être suspendu pendant un an on
a vu que dans l'union européenne et au
canada on a des gouvernements plutôt
progressiste en tout cas dans le
discours qu'il 2010
ils veulent défendre l'environnement en
revanche on sait que tout ça peut
changer très vite on l'a vu aux états
unis on est passé de obama donald trump
on l'a vu aussi au brésil avec l'arrivée
de jacques bolson haro donc on a besoin
de garanties
puis vous savez l'accord de paris à une
grande faiblesse c'est à dire que tous
les états sont obligés de prendre des
engagements
mais si le ne les tiennent pas alors il
ne se passe rien pourrait que critiquer
là justement avec cette modification
qu'on demande du conte propose pour le
sénat c'est de dire si les engagements
ne sont pas respectés alors il y aura un
impact alors il y aura un impact pour
l'état qui ne respecte pas ses
engagements de baisse d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre donc des sanctions cela
dit vous proposer monsieur leur est
entre autres de faire enlever la tribune
d'arbitrage de cet accord qui ferait
respecter donc les règles qui seraient
responsables d'imposer des sanctions si
à pau ce tribunal
alors il ya deux choses en fait dans le
détail il ya deux types de mécanismes de
règlement des différends il ya les
règlements des différends entre états
donc c'est à dire l'union européenne et
le canada quand ils sont pas d'accord
ils peuvent aller devant devant un
tribunal et se mettre d'accord ça c'est
une chose et ça nous on n'y voit pas
d'inconvénient ce qui nous pose problème
c'est ce qu'on appelle le règlement des
différends entre investisseurs et état
qui permet aux investisseurs étrangers
par les gens par exemple a attaqué une
police politique publique de l'union
européenne
ou alors une politique publique du
canada ça on pense que c'est pas
acceptable parce que c'est des tribunes
au privé c'est une justice privée qui ne
se justifie pas et d'ailleurs le canada
dans le cadre de l'accord nord américain
alena a demandé de le supprimer
d'ailleurs la supprimer et la
justification qui est invoquée par le
canada c'était de dire à cause de ces
tribunaux d'arbitrage on a été condamnée
le contribuable canadien a été condamné
à verser plus de 300 millions de dollars
canadiens
c'est pas normal aujourd'hui l'urgence
elle est écologique on doit pas donner
des moyens en plus aux investisseurs
pour se défendre
donc vous propose également sur la
question agricole monsieur leur est en
fait vous souligner qu'il ya des
décalages l'antre les normes européennes
les normes canadiennes qu'est ce que
vous proposez
où exactement mais ça en fait c'est les
règles du commerce mondial qui sont
faits comme celle ci c'est à dire que
dans l'union européenne on a interdit
certains produits certains pesticides
par exemple mais on continue à autoriser
l'importation de denrées agricoles qui
ont été traités avec ces pesticides
interne
donc du coup c'est un double effet un
double effet négatif puisque pour les
agriculteurs européens
là c'est de la concurrence déloyale eh
ben pour l'en et pour l'environnement
notamment pour la biodiversité c'est un
impact très fort aujourd'hui il ya
quarante six substances qui sont
interdits dans l'union européenne qui
sont autorisés au canada nous ce qu'on
propose c'est que on impose justement
dans le cadre du c'est à ce qu'on
appelle des clauses miroir c'est à dire
que si vous voulez vendre dans l'union
européenne
vous devez respecter les règles de
production de l'union européenne si vous
voulez vendre au canada vous devez
respecter les règles de production du
canada et c'est comme ça qu'on passe
d'un accord de libre échange à un accord
de juste échange
ouais mais monsieur leur et vous
souligner qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
grogne en europe contre cet accord là
qui est entrée en vigueur qui enfin on a
des stats étaient quand même qui montre
que l'europe en a peut-être plus profité
que le canada la balance commerciale
s'est détériorée face à l'europe au
canada au cours des premiers mois de
2010 9 vous en profiter quand même de
cet accord alors l'union européenne en
bénéficient mais le problème c'est que
le grand perdant c'est encore et
toujours le climat
aujourd'hui on est dans une urgence
climatique une urgence c'est que le
écologique qui nécessite qu'on accélère
donc nous on est pour ça qu on n'est pas
opposé à un accord par principe avec le
canada entre l'union européenne et le
canada
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'on doit avoir un
accord qui permette de mettre en place
de nouvelles normes
un accord qui permette de passer du
libre échange au juste échange et puis
juste un point le problème c'est que
l'union européenne a quand même beaucoup
à le canada a aussi augmenté ses
importations notamment de pétrole et
donc ça ça pose problème puisque on sait
qu'au canada vous utilisez le pétrole
issu des sables bitumineux qui est un
pétrole beaucoup plus émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre etc un vrai problème pour
le climat et la biodiversité
monsieur le riz le forum auquel vous
participez c'est l'occasion oui faire
valoir vos préoccupations
environnementales mais aussi toutes
sortes d'organisations des employeurs
des syndicats des regroupements
autochtone qui font valoir leurs
préoccupations est ce que c'est possible
de trouver un terrain d'entente en tous
genres entre tous ces gens là alors
aujourd'hui ce qu'on a vu parce qu on a
pu commencer là les réunions aujourd'hui
on s'est rendu compte que finalement les
seuls qui 7e qui s'opposaient c'est
toujours le patronat sinon il ya un
grand consensus entre les syndicats les
ong les représentants des peuples
autochtones pour demander une ride
vision du ceta ça c'est quelque chose
qui fait plutôt consensus donc on espère
que demain le patronat sera enfin à la
hauteur des enjeux écologiques et va
accepter qu'on puisse revoir cet accord
pour qu'il soit plus écologique mais
leur et merci beaucoup merci à vous